- If I carved a pumpkin and
put it on my front doorstep,
A, people would think I was nuts
and B, it would get stolen.
- It's just not a thing in Australia.
(quirky, upbeat keyboard music)
- This is gonna take a while.
- So, we need a knife.
- I reckon we need to take out the guts.
(laughing)
- It's so stuck.
- We're off to a good start.
- This is gonna take a while.
- It's so scary.
- That's pretty clever
the way you're doing it.
Now you got to get it out.
- Yes
- Yup, okay.
- Oh, yes.
- Looks like a million
little orange spiders
should be coming out at me.
- Now we need to fist out the seeds.
- To fist out the seeds. Okay.
- Yes.
- It does feel cooler.
- I know.
- Just get in amongst it.
- Oh.
- I know it's hands on. It's
like, it's better than TV.
- Oh I feel like I'm
squeezing someone's insides.
- I'm ready for the face.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- What shape
eyes are you making?
- Square.
- Square?
- Okay, Roy you're gonna
make a circle, do it.
Can you do a circle with this?
- At least triangle.
- You know when you do
your makeup and like
one eye is always better
than the other one?
- Yes.
- I feel like that's
happening to this pumpkin.
- Okay, let's do the math.
So it's got teeth.
- Yup.
- Like.
- We could make one of
those vomiting ones.
- I've gotta say, like
this is really tough.
(fleshy puncture)
- The nurses must just
dread this time of year.
Like, "Oh Karen we've got
another pumpkin injury."
(fleshy punctures)
- Did it.
(vomiting sounds)
- Oh, I had the worst Halloween ever, man.
- Look at that.
- Well done.
- And he looks so happy.
I wish I was as happy as this pumpkin.
- Meet Nigel the pumpkin.
Goddamn, that was just too much.
- It was fun and I'm
happy with the end result.
- [Voicover] We're really
proud of our child, here.
- Filled with absolute
joy. Just absolute joy.
- [Girl with hat] I say we
bring the tradition over here.
- I reckon we should.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Pretty good.
What do reckon Harry?
- Yes.
- I agree
- [Voiceover] I think for
Aussies who know absolutely
nothing about Halloween, I'd have never
really celebrated it.
That's pretty good.
I've you know graduated
university, graduated high school,
but this (hollow knocking)
that's my greatest achievement.
- [Voiceover] We created
a masterpiece tonight.
- [Voiceover] We did. We did. Yeah.
[Voiceover] Happy Halloween everyone.
(playful cackling)